i mean our minds are so powerful so even  just like changing the storyline  makes it a whole different game i enjoy  that place that we get to go to in these  ultras where it hurts really bad i think  that's pretty cool probably four or five  years ago  i  viewed the pain cave as like  this place that you should try to put  off as long as possible in a race like  make your pain cave be as far away from  you as you can and if you arrive to it  then you just sit in it and you try and  survive but in the past couple years  it's been  the place i want to get to so  like changing it to a place where i get  to celebrate that i made it there and  then that's where the work actually  happened so  making the pain cave bigger picturing a  chisel and just like making tunnels in  my pain cave in my brain